okay good morning everybody uh it's 10
o'clock and we're going to go ahead with
this first uh Committee of the whole
dealing with three bills which we have
retained uh this year they all address
the same topic mental health in our
schools a very very important topic uh
in front of everybody here on the
committee
uh there you should have a copy of the
agenda it basically gives our presenters
the presenters that are going to be
working with us today and
um how we will handle the quest q a the
questions and answers uh we'll have a
short period following each presenter
but then we're going to have a 30 minute
period following at the end so we can
wrap things up and really steer this
ship in a direction that we want to move
in in terms of how we're going to
address these three bills this is a this
is a huge topic uh it's a topic in which
I've been engaged just uh the other day
when we had the teacher shortage
committee that topic mental health and
the schools popped up just like that uh
when we had the trustee meeting for the
University system New Hampshire that
topic was right on the table for the 27
Trustees of the University system New
Hampshire when we had our oversight
committee here back on June 12th which
you have a copy of the doc which we had
there mental health was one of those
issues which we addressed there so it's
a a topic which I think is apropos that
we'd be looking at seriously here and
trying first to identify what is this
what are we talking about and how we can
handle it and and I know that when the
bill is introduced that hearing I had a
conversation yesterday with Senator
Waters and doe together uh dealing with
some of the the questions and I think
I'm not going to mention anything right
now because this will all come up
probably in our discussions today
I will uh let everybody know that I do
have a conflict here
um
this meeting was initially supposed to
been in the afternoon but it got in the
calendar at 10 o'clock I have a meeting
starting up at about 1105 or supposed to
start 11 with Senator dalessandro and
Senator Carson dealing with Civics
education which uh we know we have
another issue there we have to do we
appropriated one million dollars for a
program this year and so we're
addressing that so much so I'm gonna
have to get up and leave but I've asked
representative Miler uh continue with
the meeting when I leave Mel has been
the chair here and ranking person he's
been a chair of this committee I know I
know which year it was you know but it's
dating back on our time here together
and he is also the ranking rep and I
think it's very appropriate that he'd be
here seeing that the vice chair is not
here today
so with that I'd like to look at the doc
which we have here and for those people
which are here
um
the can we go around quickly and
introduce ourselves because we have uh
Kendra Lewis here from the University
system New Hampshire who is working with
a Cooperative uh extension service which
is dealing with Youth and Family
resilience programs and first aid and
all that as associated with mental
health in our schools and we also have
Melissa white and Rebecca Rebecca
fredette's not here today but uh Melissa
is very much attuned to what's going on
in this this domain this curricular
element and uh also familiar with
mtss-b which we have discussed in
previous and Gene Bergeron of course is
a frequent flyer here from the school
administrators special education
administrators Association and will also
be presenting to us today why don't we
start with you represent Balboni on that
sign wrap around just introduce yourself
huh
representative Peggy Balboni and I
represent uh Rye Greenland in
Northampton okay
I'm representative Karine cascadden I
represent the city of Berlin
hi I am representative Valerie McDonald
and I represent Salem
representative Katie pedernal I
represent wolf bro and Tuftonboro
Linda Tanner I represent Sunapee in
Springfield
Dave luno Hopkinton Beau conquered
uh Mel Miller Hopkins and bow and a part
of Concord
I'm Rick glad I come from Haverhill New
Hampshire and some of us are from the
Oliver Ford Chester
Kristen Noble Bedford
morning Muriel Hall Bowen Hopkinton
good morning hope Damon I live in
Croydon I represent Acworth Langdon
lemster Goshen Washington Springfield
I either remember one Steve Wood clock
from Conway glad you're here thank you
Margaret drive from Plainfield I
represent the rest of Sullivan County so
it's Plainfield Cornish Newport unity
Alicia leckis Hudson and Litchfield
well thank you
we have coming up first we have Kendra
Lewis uh and her cohort there
from the extension service they
presented a a short activity which
really got us thinking about mental
health by us I'm talking about the 27
Trustees of the University system uh
last week
and mental health was one of the issues
which was aside from talking about
the the lakes and the rivers of our area
and the drones which are flying over top
mental health surfaced and so with that
all right thank you I'm glad to to be
here I'm going to let you stand up and
pass some stuff out yeah so I brought my
my uh supervisor here and helping him
help me pass out some some stuff so
um if for those of you who aren't
familiar with extension where the
Outreach um or part of the Outreach arm
of the university and and
um so we focus on health and well-being
Mike here's our wonderful team leader
I'm a state specialist we approach
Health in a holistic manner so we cover
nutrition and physical activity and also
then mental behavioral health and mental
Behavioral Health is my passion and my
expertise so we shared with our Board of
Trustees
um uh an activity on Mental Health First
Aid just to give you a little idea of
what Mike has passed out there's a rack
card that says aging well that's just to
give you an idea of some of the
programming that we do in health and
well-being and extension we have an
aging population here in New Hampshire
we're growing very quickly with our
aging population so we have a lot of
programs there there you'll also see the
five healthy habits for mental health
that's from the Department of Education
I just feel like that's always a nice
little flyer to keep handy of you know
quick tips to help take care of you and
then the last is a handout that's very
um quick about you know UNH extension in
General on the front but then on the
back again it's talking about mental
health and well-being really focusing on
um on mental health for you so many of
you are probably familiar with the youth
risk behavior survey data right and
sadly we've seen the rates increase in
that we don't want to so approximately
25 percent of Youth have seriously
committed uh attempting suicide 36 or
more have reported that their mental
health has not been good most of the
time or always and that's compared to a
national average of 29 and at least 10
percent of our New Hampshire youth have
attempted suicide at least once
um and all of these rates have gone up a
lot especially during covid so this was
data that was collected in 2021 and so
it's quite a big increase that we saw
from the data that was collected in
2019.
um so I'm going to talk about one of the
programs we offer that's on the Aging
well but it's also for to focus on youth
mental health how many of you have taken
the youth Mental Health First Aid course
no at least one of you anybody back here
okay we've got a couple people great
yeah so um Mental Health First Aid we've
um we have an extension have been
delivering this course since 2016. in
2021 we kind of became a hub for the
state through funding from the
Department of Education we've been
working closely with the Bureau for
Student Wellness on that they were sort
of the Hub that kind of came to us and
so as a hub what that means is that when
an organization wants to take this
course they can come to us and we'll
help them get connected with trainers in
the state so Mental Health First Aid is
an eight-hour course it helps us learn
how to recognize signs and symptoms of
mental health challenges or maybe a
substance use uh challenge and help
somebody get the care that they need in
that moment if you think about it like
CPR for uh for mental health that's an
easy way to think about it so CPR right
we see somebody having some sort of
physical health challenge we give them
CPR and then the medical help comes and
arrives and our job is done Mental
Health First Aid is similar in that we
see somebody having a crisis we help
them in through those moments we get
them you know whatever help that they
might need and then the appropriate
medical professionals take over
so there's a couple different versions
there's an adult version which is what's
on that card so that would be adults
like myself and I take the course so
that I can support my adult peers
there's a youth version and so this
would be again for adults that want to
support the youth that either maybe it's
the youth that they work with it could
be the youth that they live with care
for it could be you know a youth that
they see in a grocery store maybe having
um a crisis there's also a teen version
where teens learn these skills so that
they could be helped for their peers and
then help that team find
um uh find an appropriate adult who can
help them then get the uh the services
that they need
so again we serve as that Hub in the
state getting people
um you know connected to instructors so
schools can come contact us say hey we
want to have a training we try to find
them some local trainers that can come
do that for them or if you're just an
individual who's interested in taking
the course we offer them monthly so that
anybody can sign up and take the course
as an individual so you don't have to be
tied to a specific organization to take
it this course is literally for anybody
um we've trained lots of schools
different school districts we have one
school district Groton anybody who it
represents Groveton here is anybody here
close yeah they trained all their bus
drivers they you know said the bus
drivers are you know somebody who
obviously they see you so they wanted to
make sure that their bus drivers were
able to see because they also see
different parts of students lives than
teachers and other school
um staff would
um Public Safety officers especially in
the Dover area they've been training all
of their police officers sheriffs all
their city workers we have Librarians
across the state who have also been
trained and we're working with the
Community Mental Health Centers as well
to you know help them help them train
people in the in the community who want
to
um so we are going to do
um an activity in just a moment again
this this course is eight hours so it
starts by teaching us what are those
early signs and symptoms if somebody's
just starting to have a mental health
challenge what are maybe some signs and
symptoms of people who are getting a
little bit worse and then people who
might be actually experiencing
um a crisis what do you think some of
those signs and symptoms might be from
anywhere along the continuum
symptoms someone might be having a
challenge
yeah
change in Behavior changing Behavior yes
what else
being withdrawn being withdrawn yeah
substance abuse substance abuse yep
yeah
yes go for it
over or under eating yes yeah changes in
eating yes changes in eating is a is a
big one yeah so there's there's all
these signs that we could be seeing and
so again the the course goes through
what are the ones that we might see kind
of early on what are those ones that are
oh this is getting a little bit worse
than what are ones that we see
um when somebody is in crisis so this
program is really good as an early
intervention when those signs and
symptoms start showing up and trying to
stop it from getting to that crisis mode
you know let's catch what are those
early symptoms so we can try and get
somebody the appropriate help so that
they don't go into crisis but it still
prepares us to know what does it look
like if somebody is
um in a crisis situation uh people learn
an action plan it's got a cute little
acronym called algae so they can learn
you know how do we assess
um the situation how can we listen
non-judgmentally and really validate
what somebody is experiencing and give
them the assurance that they need in
that moment encourage the appropriate
professional help and then encourage
urge them to also take care of
themselves because this is really
emotionally taxing for us to be
providing that mental health care to
other people so how do we make sure to
check in with ourselves and take care of
ourselves there
so we're going to do an activity that
we're jumping towards the end of the uh
course and we're going into crisis mode
we're going to do an activity that is an
auditory hallucination so we're going to
kind of get an experience of what it
might be like for somebody who is
experiencing auditory hallucination so
we can kind of build a little empathy
there
um and have that so I've got two people
who've been voluntold by representative
Ladd so representative is it caskadin
but you've been volunteled
ahead of you okay that's all you're
going to do is be reading this to you
become here it'll be great 529 short
yeah so you're gonna maybe if you two
stand right there in the middle would be
great so
you're
your job representative
she's going to be reading to you how to
get to the new library in town and your
goal is to get to the new library in
town I am not going to make this easy
for you but your job is to try and get
can I have some distance uh no you'll be
okay you'll be okay so you're just gonna
read this part and you're gonna do your
best to get to the new library in town
go for it ready
the new library is amazing you're almost
why are you talking to her just a little
bit to go don't trust her start out
going West on Owen Avenue
and after half a mile turn right why
if you don't know
how was that experience for you terrific
yeah
can you get to the library
no can anybody in this room get to the
library
no no can you get to the library
probably right Fish Hatchery it's a big
Green Building
when you looked at him did you see
anything that indicated during the
headlights right so probably struggling
to focus a little bit right oh yeah yeah
yeah
right anybody anybody else notice
anything or did you have any feelings of
like what like what did that bring up
for you going through that
yes
um somebody did cry on Friday
um yeah I mean it is it's hard to think
yeah no and so this is um thank you very
much I appreciate can you get a round of
applause
so this is one of the favorite
activities that people go through in
Mental Health First Aid this is in both
the youth and the adult version
um I think this activity is a great
example of what's at the core of this
program is really building that
understanding and empathy of what people
are going through
um because when we see a physical
um challenge we can see it right if I'm
physically injured you'd be able to see
it you'd be able to have a little
empathy and understanding because you
can see what I am going through but we
can't see those with mental health
challenges and so activities like this
can give us that opportunity to learn
what people might be struggling with and
then we can you know be there and be
their support and help really validate
what their experience is so thank you
for your time thank you again so much
um for letting me know can you try to
then relate what we just did here to
what's going on in the classroom when we
have a child coming into the room that's
dealing with an environment a behavior
environment they're coming from or
there's other issues going on Within
family or with their lives or with
another student
one of their chances of really achieving
in that class academically yeah they're
going to struggle a lot right because we
feel safe at home if we don't feel safe
in general it's very hard for us to
learn and if we're bringing in
um you know experiences from home or
again if we're struggling with another
student that's in our classroom it's
going to be very hard to concentrate our
mind is going to be focused on that
situation and trying to stay safe versus
actually trying to learn what's
happening so um again it can we might be
seeing these as children acting out a
lot of times right that we we and we
label them maybe as problem children or
somebody that's just misbehaving and
that might not be the case it could be
that they are struggling with um their
situation and they need again a little
bit of us to understand what they are
experiencing so that we can then help
them okay how can I create this safe
environment in my classroom so that they
can be in a situation where they can
learn
yes oh yes representative
questions yeah one is you had mentioned
algae yes uh was an acronym for an
action plan what do those what does that
stand for yes so algae the A is for
assess the risk for suicide or harm
L is listening non-judgmentally
G is giving assurance and information we
sometimes call this hope with facts um
so usually people need a little bit of
Hope but we don't want to give them
false information right right so Mental
Health First Aid really goes over
um a lot of statistics and facts so
people can be prepared with those
the first e is for encouraging
appropriate professional help
um and so again we work to make sure
that we have local resources available
so people know okay this this is your
local Community Mental Health Center or
these are some other places you want to
go in your portion of the state or we
have other um you know National hotlines
and and things at the ready to share and
then the last e is encouraging self-help
and other support strategies great thank
you and one other last question is
do you differentiate between behavioral
health and mental health
and what what kind of signs might be the
difference no so in the course no
they'll be showing they'll talk about
both of those together yeah together
yeah so then you'll see you know maybe
what are some of the physical
um signs so that could be you know
somebody's looking more disheveled than
they usually do right
um or then Behavioral Health would be
some of the things like not eat you know
your changes in your eating habits
um mental health would be
there's signs which are things that we
can observe like that and then there's
symptoms which are the things we can
observe which would be like what are the
cognitive thoughts that people might be
telling themselves so then we know what
some of those are again when they're
early on in the crisis than their
worsening or you know when they're in
crisis mode what are some of the common
thoughts people are having so then we
know okay this is what people might be
thinking at this time right if they're
in crisis mode they might be thinking
about suicide so we need to be asking
them specifically about that so that it
does go over both both of those yeah
representative
yes thank you how do you teach people to
listen
to listen non-judgmentally or listen in
general just listen in general without I
guess it would be a non-judgmental thing
because one of the problems we have is
that everybody is supposed to have an
opinion
so I think it's very difficult for
people to just listen to what somebody's
saying what kinds of programs do you
have to to teach listening skills yeah I
would say we don't have a program that
teaches just listening skills but this
one had like does spend time practicing
listening and going through like time to
to have somebody talk about maybe a
situation they're going through not
necessarily a crisis or a mental health
challenge but they practice that active
listening where you have to repeat back
what the person just said I would think
that's actually embedded in some of our
youth programming too that we know it's
an important skill so whenever we can in
workshops we're like we're going to
practice active listening because it's a
good skill to have and it can be
challenging for people
um with the list of non-judgmentally
peace that is the part of it as well
that there's an opportunity to look at
what are some statements we might say
that are not helpful and what are
statements that we could say that are
helpful and so that goes through that
practicing again of I'm trying to just
listen to somebody and have them tell me
what's going on with them and how can I
be a part of that conversation and not
give my opinion because my opinion might
be saying something that's not helpful
to them so what can I say that instead
validates what they're saying to me yeah
yes our guinea pig over there yeah
yeah
thank you chairman thank you for your
presentation a couple quick questions on
the youth mental health yeah you said
that's an eight-hour course yes okay is
it available online yes okay and then
the third one about if any how many
school districts in the state have
participated in this or are
participating in this the terms of
trying to faculty yeah so that's a
question I unfortunately don't have the
answer to part of it is because we are
not the only ones who offer the course
so there could be we have several
community
Mental Health Centers who also offer the
course and they have different funding
than us so we might be talking together
but we're not necessarily sharing that
information so for example Manchester
has a very active Mental Health Center
and they also have another organization
that does youth Mental Health First Aid
we pretty much passed off our Manchester
requests to them because they can meet
those so
um I'm not not sure on that
unfortunately okay yeah thank you thank
you Carolyn you're welcome further
questions yes representative Damon
thank you representative Woodcock for
asking two of my three questions that's
does the online version of the First Aid
course have an interactive component for
example with practicing the active
listening yeah so what um what the
online course means is that there's also
a blended option so
um participants do two hours of it by
themselves first where they're watching
some videos they do a little um kind of
knowledge check quiz and they learn the
basics of the algae plan so they can do
that on their own for two hours then the
other six hours is led by a trained
instructor that portion can either be in
person or still online and so that's
when they get the opportunity to
practice some of these skills so again
it'll go through some different
scenarios
um and then they can start saying okay
here I've watched this video we've read
the scenario let's look at what are some
of those signs and symptoms that
somebody might be experiencing and they
actually get to then practice the algae
plan together so there's only two hours
of it that's really solo and then the
other six is with the instructors and
other people in the course but it can
still be done over Zoom we do most of
our classes over Zoom right now
yeah
thank you just going to repeat of this
it is free right now so thank you to the
Department of Education for funding it
for us for the last two years it is
currently free
um and so we're hoping to um be able to
continue offering it for free great
thank you yeah that was a question I was
going to ask too and I Melissa's back
there and maybe the department can help
us out with that
um I don't know whether I should be
calling you a doctor with the PHD that
you have but but uh it's it's really
amazing to me that we have the
Cooperative Extension Service out of the
University system now I always thought
that was dealing with soils and birds
and the wildlife and but now it looks
like you really dug out and challenging
us with these areas of of need yeah and
how well are is this program is this
operating as a silo are you working in
conjunction with the community mental
Health's uh centers and with doe and
other is there any way of tying all this
together for specifically my mental
first aid or yes yes yeah no we are
working so we also um just received a
samsa grant for the adults Mental Health
First Aid
um and several other organizations in
New Hampshire also received the same
Grant
um so we're working together so that
we're not
um a not competing for each other and
that there's not overlap but we're also
learning from one another on how we can
um you know work together to increase
our reach so for example Manchester's
Community Health Center is very specific
organizations that they have to meet for
the grant they might have requests that
they can't meet because of capacity so
they come to us so that we can try and
meet that need that whatever
organization might be happening same
with the Department of Education they
know that we are
um you know doing doing mental health
first aid for for the Youth version so I
have my contact there regularly sending
people to me
um to say Hey you know UNH extension can
help you get get trained so we're
working with those Partners as much as
we can
um to help meet the needs of prosperity
um I'm gonna try to get the questions
done by about 10 30 because I think
Melissa do you have to be out of here by
11 today yes okay
uh just question about the book yeah if
people are doing that online do they
have the option to order the book is
that free or the book they get an
electronic copy
um and so they could order the the book
I think is 25 if they wanted a hard copy
and we can help people get that
unfortunately for us because you get um
a an electronic copy if we buy the book
we're technically paying for you twice
for the course
um but we you know we try to work with
people so that they can get what they
need that's the benefit of doing it in
person when you do it in person you're
able to get a hard copy of the book
because we know a lot of people like to
have those yeah yeah uh so this is uh
primarily focused at adults or or our
students also involved I mean I'm
concerned about the issue of students
who are not engaged in the whole issue
of active listening or dealing with
their peers and problem solving Etc so
does this have any relationship up to
student engagement so the youth and
adult versions are all for adults to
take them and for either adults to
support other adults or adults to
support youth there is a teen version it
that's for ages or sorry for grades 10
to 12 where they then learn
um similar skills so
um Dover High School has been a great
example of that that they've been
implementing it it's about the course is
shorter I think it's six 45-minute
lessons and so they do those about once
a week or they might spread it out a
little bit more so that they can have
time to really learn and reflect on what
they've done in there so then it gives
teens that opportunity to uh to practice
things like listening and then how their
goal is not to they they can't provide
support for their peer right they're not
trained for that it's just to help them
in that moment and say I know this adult
at our school is trained in youth Mental
Health First Aid or can be a help for
you let's go talk to the school nurse or
let's go talk to this librarian so it's
helping them just quickly in that moment
and then getting them to an adult who
can help support them representative
Luna
I think touched on what I wanted to find
out about maybe as um as this work
session proceeds into the fall if we
could get some um you know expertise
from Dover yeah or any other students
that are that are implementing the 6x45
yeah I'm sorry 6x45 team yeah
um a curriculum that could be
yeah I think there's a lot going on I
didn't even know you had something going
on in Haverhill uh oh yeah that yeah and
so
um I think this is a good idea that we
do pull people in from the schools and
just incorporate this into our a book of
knowledge here so when we do make some
decisions how and we're going to handle
all this
it's important Patty did you have
something I just wanted to say to throw
off the um in Manchester I know the
mental health center also trains the
fire department and police department
which helps in the way that they respond
to calls yeah so it's not just School
related it's it's good for all
responders it is yes thank you and and
Mental Health First Aid has actually
made modules specific for
um Fire EMS Public Safety officers and
so um a lot of we are seeing a lot of
communities gaining more interest in
doing that because as you said it
changes how they can respond to
um to Christ this moment and they're
just getting the knowledge that we need
so we're really excited to see so many
of our Public Safety officers interested
in wanting to do the training again
Dover Stratford county has had they have
multiple sheriffs that are trained to
deliver the program their whole police
department has been trained so they
they're another just really good example
of That So yeah thank you thank you very
much Kendra one last question throw it
up there either also make sure everybody
gets my card we'll come back
I was just wondering if you've targeted
the audience
um are there is there any research on
someone for self-help let's say you end
up being the the person that takes it
but you're suffering from mental health
issues itself is there a have you gotten
any feedback I haven't gotten any I
would say anecdotally yes
um from people who I know who have taken
it but I don't have any hard research
and I don't think I've seen seen any
from
um the actual program that or National
Council for mental well-being who
designed this program but that's a great
question I don't think that they've
looked at that yet but I would say
anecdotally yes for sure it's a benefit
because then you get to know your own
signs and symptoms right I was thinking
yeah thank you great thank you very much
Kendra yeah and you know I we really
appreciate your coming down and sharing
this it's been very informative
okay so the next person uh well the
Department of Education if you have do
you have others with you
Melissa white division director for
learner support at the Department of
Education and I have my colleagues here
with me thank you Kelly Rambo division
excuse me not division director
um Bureau administrator for wellness and
nutrition
Rebecca Bureau administrator for special
education oh you did make it today
Rebecca congratulations you might have
to scoot out but okay great so we have
uh some folks here from the Department
have a wealth of knowledge and you know
I was briefly on the phone with um
Melissa yesterday and I know that when
we had the bill first presented to us
there were a lot of questions regarding
you know where we Place Mental Health in
our statute language uh how does mtssb
relate to this uh and the questions went
on and on and on so let's just try to
listen to what they may be imparting to
us right now and then we'll go with the
questions and answers following that
that good sounds good so uh currently uh
rsa193 e2a substantive educational
content of an adequate education has
health and wellness education and then
when we get into the uh Ed 306.40 b2g
health education then is a little bit
more explicit about what is included
within that health and wellness
education and mental health is um
specifically identified as a component
of K-12 curriculum in health education
so it is currently already a requirement
to include that curriculum in your
health and wellness education program
our current standards for health
education right now are a tad bit
outdated 2003 was the last time that was
done currently at the national level
they are in the process of
updating the national standards once
those have been rolled out then the
department is going to go through the
process of gathering our constituents to
go through our own internal updating
process but we want to make sure we
include those national standards because
we've gone through in the past where
we've gone through and updated our
standards and then nationally standards
get rolled out and then we have to kind
of go back and and do a lot of matching
up so that is why
um you might look at our current health
curriculum Frameworks and they have
specified mental health education and
what that looks like at the elementary
middle and high school level
but there is some outdated language
there is some things that need to be
included but uh I noticed when we look
specifically at the language that was
put into the proposed legislation when
we're looking at anxiety disorders and
and going into a kind of a uh that level
of specificity that's actually included
in the existing Frameworks at this time
so I think that
um the Department's plan was just to
move forward with updating those
Frameworks so that the school districts
can then have that information
use that as they're looking at their
curriculum that they want to adopt in
order to meet the standards but right
now school districts
um
should have
mental health curriculum that they have
implemented and are teaching in our
okay go ahead represent Balboni thank
you and thank you for taking my question
um
you mentioned that schools should have
them um how do you are there
specific curriculums that are
recommended at the doe and they can
choose from or are they just coming up
with their own so this is where it gets
a little bit tricky because it there is
a statute that says the Department of
Education and the State Board of
Education are not allowed to
um dictate a curriculum so we cannot
choose a curriculum and say you have to
teach this however
um we have the Frameworks we have the
standards and then at the local level
it's in statute that they are
responsible for determining which
curriculum they would like to use in
order to meet the standards
um currently we do not have anything
specific for health education that we
put out as a recommendation it can get a
bit challenging to put out
recommendations for a curriculum because
then you have a a number of vendors and
this is across all of our content areas
like we'll put our curriculum out you
put this curriculum out ours should be
on there too and then it gets to be a
pretty exhaustive list and since that is
determined at the local level we usually
um leave it to the local level to
determine what they want to use in order
to meet the standards
yes representative would it be helpful
knowing the national standards of being
revised and a Frameworks and I was 20
years old
would it be helpful to put a survey out
to schools to find out what they are
doing or is it better to just wait to
see what the Nationals are and send it
out and and we could do that um we've
done that in the past when we're
surveying some of our other content
areas yeah
what's what's most widely used and we've
done that in the past too if we're
looking at
um particularly during covet if we're
looking at purchasing or like Discovery
Education you know how many school
districts are out there using Discovery
Education there's a lot there's a lot
that want access it's worth it to buy a
state level license for all schools to
be engaged with so we could definitely
do A needs assessment on that piece
survey that failed as to what they are
utilizing but if you do that can you
also be
determining if they're training people
to import you know we have the
curriculum but the instruction is a part
that I'm really concerned about who is
the one is providing this instruction is
a classroom teacher who just came out of
unh prepared to deliver this uh program
uh is it a nurse within the building
that's been there and and familiar with
it uh I'd like to know in the districts
how this is being conveyed
sure imparted to students and I think
that's something we could include in our
query as to how you know who is
responsible for for teaching that
curriculum I know in some school
districts education teacher some it may
be that's actually in the law 189 10
Roman one right the Department of
Education shall survey school districts
biannually and receive reports on
compliance with this section and we have
gotten that report back and I was amazed
when I looked at that report that there
are some schools even high schools are
putting no we didn't touch that topic
even though it's required in statute
um and so yeah I think that was going to
be an a September deal that I was going
to bring up because there's a lot of it
that's that's that information that you
provided us
is really showing there's some holes
right and I think that's similar to
something we've we discovered a couple
weeks ago with another compliance report
that hadn't been uh put together so
maybe maybe getting uh getting the last
several of these so that and maybe a
trend
is it getting better is it are we
I I think that's all all good stuff we
should be familiar with uh I those those
surveys have been done annually is that
correct I will double check it's either
annually or uh or buy anything yeah yeah
buy annually yeah so we should have some
information but it's only as good as
what the what's being entered by the
school district correct so and and uh
there are those districts which it's
very amazing I mean there's some large
schools saying we aren't doing it
um
yes
thank you
the national standards that you said are
currently being revised and if I got
this right they go back to 2003 or our
standards go back to 2000 their
standards as well
so they haven't revised the mental
health education standards for 20 years
exactly
and it's my understanding that they were
in the process of of doing that and then
of course I don't know if the excuse is
just being used as kova but then it's
like oh okay covid that set us back but
they're anticipating within the next
year at least according to their website
they're anticipating to roll those out
within the next year
yes represent Tanner and then
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question I'm wondering
when the state school board or local
school boards give approval to schools
uh if they consider any that whether
they're meeting the requirement for
health Ed or any other uh part of the
adequate education standards
but I may need to check in with Caitlin
Davis's division the division of
analytics because they are the the team
that collects the data they are the team
that does the school approval component
I do the standards and the content and
they handle that piece but I could
definitely check in with them on on that
piece of it it's my understanding that
the schools when they go through the
approval process they do have to provide
um their curriculum but I could be
I I don't know if we actually collect
the actual curriculum or just the name
of the curriculum oh we're using you
know so and so for our math curriculum
or if it's if it's down to that level of
specificity I don't know if we actually
look at and then match up
uh to the um actual standards whether
all of that's addressed
representative Cornell
the new 306 standards change all of the
shell requires to May requires so if
those passed
no one will have to do anything correct
the new Ed 306 take those elements out
it will say they have the topic the
subject if you want to call it that but
then all the
areas of Health for example if you look
at what was in the oversight committee
there enlisted under the ed306 that
mental health I think it's item G on
there correct
is to be taught in schools the as from
my understanding of course those new
rules are not complete at this point in
time they're still going through the
hearing process with the public
so that has to come back and I guess the
depart the state board has to take a
look at that but uh I'm concerned that
if you take mental health out of G there
on 306 where else is it mentioned in
statute now as a previous member of gel
car we always had the rule that the rule
has to reference a statute
if it doesn't reference a statute where
is the state board coming up with this
requirement it's it basically becomes
really
an unfunded issue so we're we are
concerned that you know by taking it out
then it's in this and I think that's
where her Senator Waters it was when he
put this together saying that it's an
issue in the schools how do we ensure
that it's taught in schools now or at
least referenced because we don't
whether it's taught or not that's a
local
local thing and unfortunately that I
think is very characteristic of a lot of
different subjects in this state on
terms of the department really either
one not having the staff to dig down
into the schools and that's what we're
looking for uh Dr Green Nate to try to
get more analytics support unfortunately
that didn't make it into the budget
and so
um and I think too if we look at um
uh Edwards for 3101 there's this
component in there under the daily
physical activity program being required
in schools and then there's this
component of mental health that's in
there I I think that
it does give schools leeway but by
having it in that physical education
piece I think then that kind of cues
administrators to think oh I've got to
stick it into physical education does it
belong with physical education maybe
maybe not but uh
it's kind of um inconsistent as far as
where it's placed throughout some of our
some of our guidance for for the schools
as far as the rules Come Around and then
the statute as well so I think
clarification representative and then
representative if that's what we want if
we want to specify what it is that
should be taught in the schools then
we have to be clear about where we put
it and I think that's an issue for this
committee yeah
yeah I understand the and thank you for
taking my question I understand the
issue of curriculum and mandates Etc the
question that I have is is the
department concerned about the mental
health of our students absolutely and
and how what are the thank you and what
are the mechanisms that the department
uses
to gear the mental health
of our students and what is the mental
health right now as we end this school
year of our students thank you for that
question because it gives me in the
opportunity to kind of tout some of the
programs that we are doing and I think
this is a part of the discussion we also
had yesterday as far as there's you know
a difference between
mental health education as far as we're
educating all of the students on Mental
Health how to take care of your mental
health how to be aware of that then
there's this component of serving those
acute needs or the needs of students
that are presenting with mental health
needs and so two different areas
um and a lot of our programming right
now to do with you know mtssb
um youth Mental Health First Aid a lot
of our programs so want the office of
student wellness as well as the Bureau
of special education and instructional
support are looking at how do we do
programming holistically to meet the
needs of students we want to look at
those acute needs mtssb so that the
students are getting that tier two and
tier three intervention supports getting
access to some of those higher level
Professional Services that need to be
provided by those experts that have that
experience in that field in addition to
building those resiliency factors
because we talk a lot about
um
serving acute needs but we have to work
on building those resiliency factors and
the biggest part when we look at
prevention and supporting students
mental health is having that connection
to community having that connection to
being a part of something and so when we
look at building programming we just had
the fortunate uh experience this morning
to have our junior junior ROTC
from uh down in Hudson talk about how
ROTC has impacted the lives of students
and how they were able to feel a part of
something and now they have leadership
skills they have responsibility they
want to step up and give back to their
community so having those various
opportunities holistically for students
to be able to choose whether they want
to be a part of Equine Therapy or they
want to be a part of a sports team or
they want to be a part of Robotics
making those available so that it's not
just dependent upon you know being in a
larger school district and having access
to those opportunities so I think we're
looking at those resiliency factors the
mental health education for tier one or
all students and then that MTS is being
kind of offering that all together
because if I look at our covered relief
funds it's not just about the academic
piece what can we offer for schools to
utilize funds for after school before
school summer programming that are
engaging for to students they're active
they're they're communicating they're
connecting so that those are some
examples of the multiple programs that
we are offering but in our Bureau
bureaus we usually as our leadership
team get together and look at when we're
offering Services when we're doing a
contract when we're taking in a grant
let's think about holistically how we're
going to serve all of our student groups
because we are seeing and you can weigh
in on this a little bit more Becky
increase in the number of needs for for
students and addressing mental health
needs
you know I know that there are there are
some who feel
that schools should not deal with the
social emotional issues of students
and how do you respond to those who
object
to the issue of schools dealing with the
social and emotional issues that some
say it that's the parents responsibility
that's a family responsibility not the
school's responsibility how do you
respond to that
that that is a tricky one because there
are definitely
um
uh
uh perspectives on what what should be
included and should social emotional
health and wellness be offered I think
that it's the piece about education so
that
um families feel connected to
understanding what all those components
are what is included within that within
that social and emotional Wellness piece
um
I I think that it's also important to
have constituents involved through the
process so that when we're looking
specifically at
um implementing this type of legislation
having those voices having the schools
come in having families and parents come
in and talking a little bit about their
concerns perhaps if they
um have that feeling towards this that
they can have that dialogue and and be a
part of the process I think that that
has been our response because we
definitely hear from people that are
very supportive people that are very
um very concerned and we try to balance
both but it really takes all of us to to
address the the concerns and provide the
education as far as what is included
when we talk about mental health
education
represent Luna
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
for for taking my question Ms White
um when um when when Ms Lewis was was
here speaking earlier she um she handed
out this
um from the UNH Cooperative Extension
and on the back of it it says that 36
actually says 36 plus reported that
their mental health talk about students
reported that their mental health was
not good quote most of the time or
always compared to a national average of
29 and so it's sort of a two-part part
question
um does does that reporting is that
reporting consistent with with any data
that has been collected by the
department and then number two does the
fact that that a student reports that
their mental health is not good does
that um how does that impact their
ability to to learn
so I think for the first part of the
question really the only data that the
department has to look at is the youth
uh Behavior youth risk behavior survey
unfortunately and we've been very vocal
about our concerns is that the data from
that comes out almost two years after
it's administered so we're always
looking in our rears when it comes to
that
um so it's hard to look at you know the
2021 results to see how that relates to
2023 especially with the past two years
of there's been a lot of a lot of change
in that short period of time
um so that's the the challenge that we
do have we don't have access to
um serving students directly about that
piece but the programs that we sponsor
the programs that we contract with
through vendors through Partnerships
through memorandums of understanding
with UNH or with the behavioral health
institutes they are able to gather some
of that that data because they are on
the ground working locally in the
schools and providing that information
um so unfortunately I can't answer
specifically it's just like with numbers
and data that we've we are seeing
increases a lot of it is anecdotal
um and that we're hearing
um
the second part is
when we look at applying for a lot of
these federal grants to meet a lot of
the
um
the programming needs at the local level
implementing at the school level it gets
a little bit tricky because we've had
this influx of money and now it's
starting to dry up a little bit when we
look at the funding sources for the
Youth Mental Health First Aid we had a a
robust grant that was able to provide
that support and we have that for
another year and then it's it's going
away so we look at okay we are able to
provide that Statewide please take
advantage of it
um but then in a year from now we have
to reevaluate and then we have to
prioritize so I think that's always in
the back of our minds is how can we
braid multiple sources of funding in
order to meet the needs we were lucky
enough to get an allocation into hb2
specifically for mtssb but again it's
that balancing of
what needs are out there in the schools
how can we utilize different ways in
order to meet those needs I know that
um some of the schools when they offer a
youth mental health for State training a
district might actually pay for that and
then they'll open it up to multiple
community members multiple uh Partners
in other schools so I think some of the
data they were talking about you know
they could look at specifically what
they were offering but what you're
seeing in other school districts or
other offerings across the state
um we may not have those actual numbers
but it is widespread as far as how
they're reaching out
Mr Shea I just want to follow up on that
so I I didn't quite get get an answer on
um on on the second uh part so I just
want to reframe it a little bit thank
you um and and I know you Tim thanks for
your your input with regards to Grants
and things like that to help improve
this but I just want to put this in a
little context
um currently the state is spending close
to 3.5 bit the state all in towns local
taxpayers state funding federal grants
uh three and a half billion dollars a
year to educate 165 000 students across
the state and if 36 percent of them are
experiencing
reported that their mental health was
not good most of the time or always so
one-third of um uh a little over a third
so so you know a little over a third of
000 would be uh somewhere about sixty
thousand students across the state
I want to make sure that that our our
ability to to adequately educate these
these students is uh is is you know
proceeding forward in a way that's
beneficial for the students and
beneficial to the investment the 3.5
billion dollars a year we spend so if
we're missing out on a hundred thousand
dollar Grant
um it would seem to me that we're
jeopardizing a significant portion more
than a third more than a billion dollars
of of our own uh investment in in
educating kids so so with that as the
backdrop
um do you see a connection or does the
department recognize a connection
between the ability of students to learn
and what their current mental health
um uh condition is
I would say absolutely okay thanks
representative Tanner
and I think it's not just my opinion I
think that that most research is shown
um I have a master's in educational
psychology and I think all if I can
think back to the many years ago where I
went through that program that was very
much a part of it that's that's good I
want to thank you for that because
because I think you know I'm not trained
in this area anecdote I would absolutely
agree with what you said because I think
it makes it makes um a lot of sense
um uh but uh but I think it's important
for the committee to hear that based on
your professional experience and
training
um that that there is an indelible
linkage between uh between the two and
um and and uh and you know if there are
roadblocks
um
in place that make it difficult for the
Department to
um to to to to to help
um these students learn better whether
that's whether that's availability of
non-academic
um surveys or whether that's funding
from the state or federal programs I
think it's it's important uh for us to
be able to to take a look at how to how
to
eliminate these roadblocks so that we
can do a better job for um uh for all of
our our students and for all of our
taxpayers that are spending three and a
half billion dollars a year to educate
them
I'm gonna have to leave here in a few
moments but uh one of the things we
haven't gotten to and maybe perhaps when
Jane comes up uh you can be asking these
questions I'm concerned about the
intervention process that's within the
schools uh you may have Rebecca you may
have a student that might be having a
an IEP need and you don't know exactly
what realm it is in but obviously
something's going on in the classroom
the child doesn't look like they're
achieving so the process the classroom
teacher has is do you refer to an
intervention team that makes the
decision not well we're we're going to
talk to other teachers had the kid last
year or we're going to be talking to
some of the Specialists within the
building or we're going to go to our
school counselor our psychologist and
and try to discern where do we go do we
go special ed do we go to some other
strategy
do schools out there today have that
intervention process in place
or is the teacher sort of left stranded
in terms of how to deal with this child
so for some schools um they would have
the multi-tiered systems of support for
behavior that um our office of social
emotional Wellness supports so that
would be where they're supporting all
students but then they're also looking
at those tier two and tier three
students but but within that you're also
going to have a group of students who
would also qualify for special education
because mental health is not just a
special education issue it's it's all
students and so you you are going to
have a population of students that that
have special needs but you're also going
to have many more students who do not
have special needs I think you have two
systems that are trying to work together
to determine is it just a mental health
issue or does it does it rise to the
level of it's also a special education
um need that they have to address so you
you most schools have teams that they go
to that they would refer the student to
that would refer that would review all
of those that information they review
what they did last year what it was like
last year they would talk with parents
to find out what the student what's
going on at home
um you would hope that all of those
Services would wrap around to support
that student and then the team would be
able to determine if it's they need some
supports through mtssb or no we really
need to go to a referral for special
education
um I think what we're finding is that
not all schools have the supports they
need for the mental health issues and
that their only recourse is to go to
special education so we don't have the
supports we need for mental health over
here maybe they don't have mtssb or
maybe they haven't addressed it in their
District so we're going to come to
special education because we know they
have some of the pieces that will help
so I think for us that's where we see an
increase in the number of referrals to
special education and the number of
requests for support for students that
we may not have seen before or that may
have gone through a different route
before
how many of the schools have
intervention teams which actively
involved and have participation from the
okay
I'm gonna have to leave right now so
represent miles going to take over and
yeah thank you uh representative Tanner
thank you
um I'd like to talk a little bit or hear
a little bit more about
um the teacher preparation part of this
uh health education most schools can't
afford to hire just a health education
specialist
um that's that's trained in that so
oftentimes health education is taught as
somebody mentioned before by the school
nurse maybe the phys ed teacher
um maybe the Science Biology teacher uh
sometimes gets roped into teaching
Health
um and I'm just wondering what the
department
what they see first of all as uh the
community colleges are Granite State
college system uh our University system
how how
integrated into that is uh with teacher
preparation preparation on teaching
health or the ability to get a minor in
teaching health I know Plymouth
to my knowledge Plymouth is the only
University that in the state teacher
prep that actually gives a certificate
of a Bachelor of Science in health
education and also professional
development whether the department is
actually providing
um grants or whatever to give money to
Local Schools to do professional
development in the teaching of health
education and Mental Health Service
first aid for example even though that's
free but the other mental health issues
that that need to be addressed in in a
health education course outside of just
providing their curriculum so teacher
prep great thank you for that question
so with the teacher preparation programs
I can't speak specifically to that
because I don't know
um actually what uh you know what
requirements are as far as different
colleges or different programs
throughout our state that I think we
would have to actually do some sort of
analysis or survey in order to to get
that specific information
with the professional development
opportunities at the department level we
offer those professional development
opportunities mostly through the office
of Social and emotional Wellness but we
do combine those programs with some of
the offerings that we do with our covert
relief funds title programming
um
and if a school is specifically looking
at doing A needs assessment and wanting
to utilize some of their funding in
order to support that type of
professional development we can help
them to kind of figure out how to use
their funding in order to do that if
they want to bring that specifically
into their school I know there was one
on just this past week that was one a
school that was wanting to bring
some sort of leadership training for
their students specifically with regards
to mental health supports and so we're
looking at trying to help them figure
out how what kind of funding sources
they can use in order to do that so I
think it's a mixture
some components driven by the state
level some components driven by the
local level as far as they're seeing
what their needs are what they want and
and getting the buy-in of their teams as
far as uh you know how to move forward
selecting specific trainings and that
so uh what I'm concerned with is the
actual preparation of the person that's
going to deliver the health education
curriculum correct
um and
from my experience which is you know
back in the Dark Ages but the
professional development uh you know a
couple hours on the afternoon or
something or a one day thing was more
how to incorporate some of the things
into whatever you did teach so that or
your interaction with students or you
know if you were coaching maybe how to
handle certain situations but but
other than
other than that I've seen I've seen and
heard in this committee from people
testifying some really
bad mistakes people have made trying to
do their best in teaching health
education and with the current
climate surrounding teaching right now
I think it's really important that we
support and try to encourage and also
offer opportunities for people who are
teaching health or who have you know the
biology teacher that said signs up brand
new and they say oh yeah you have to
teach nine weeks of Health as well to
get this job
some some support from the from the
Department from our our College systems
to offer them uh really ex experience
Direction and guidance and instruction
on how to instruct health education
and I'm just wondering if if that's
something that the department could look
into or that might be put on your agenda
I think it's something we could you know
do A needs assessment do an evaluation
it gets tricky and I speak my experience
as far as uh just trying to implement
the science of reading
at the teacher preparation program we
have a number of uh you know studies
that have been done about signs of
reading how you know reading is being
taught half of our kids in the state are
not reading at grade level even just to
Rally around and make change at the
higher education level for that
component has been significantly
challenging so we would really need to
have not just the department looking at
it but it would have to be an effort
among multiple constituents our partners
in higher education our partners in the
community at the community level local
education agencies administrators
teachers that's something we really need
to have buy-in and want and and everyone
being on board to working towards
improving that it's not something that
just the department could could take on
and move the needle on it have to be
everyone involved
representative woodcock
thank you representative Milo I'd like
if I may go back and follow up on a
question about representative lag when
he's talking about the intervention
teams
um and I think it was referred to you
actually uh
there is not at the dimension team
present
um would this come out of the category
then of other health issues that's the
first and the spare referral and my
second question to that would be
it was determined that the that the
students not succeeding academically
because of mental health issues versus
uh skill issue perhaps
um what's the next step
so yes it could be um under other health
impairment if they it is determined that
it's impacting them educationally
um I think where the
where the issue comes in is that um is
it is it impacting them to the point
that
um they need specially designed
instruction because that's the tenet of
special education is you have to have
specially designed instruction and what
what specially designed instruction
would you provide or do they need more
Mental Health Services and
um how is this is the school even able
to provide that level of mental health
services that they need so that's where
you come to
um determine is it is it a special
education issue or is it a mental health
issue that we aren't able to
um support this is this has come up a
lot when we've talked about the episodes
of treatment that was another bill that
came to the to this committee this year
was
um DHHS is trying to support those
students with their mental health issues
but then there's no um then how do we
make sure that they ensure that they
access their education and trying to
support that that way because there's
this gap between districts don't have
the money to support it but they need
this mental health support and the
district are trying to support it but
just can't so this it's it's a it's
convoluted it's hard to explain
um but I think districts are trying to
address it and they address it either
through special education or they try to
address it with um outside agencies but
not
they don't have the resources it hasn't
been something that they've been dealing
with to this level before
follow up thank you sir
um to that point then um if we
understand that uh even based on a
two-year-old data but if we understand
that a lot of our youngsters currently
in schools have significant uh mental
health issues that are impacting their
academic performance they may not be
special ed particularly until after they
go through that identification process
is there anything doe is doing
um uh or is there anything that their
local school I mean school's doing their
own little part of things but I thought
Theo is doing as a unified approach to
we have a mental health crisis amongst a
third of our youngsters in high school
who may not be need to go in the special
ed system and spend a little time and
money not being treated well there
um no I don't mean this not well you
know right that's not the right service
there well what what is that next step
as a state or as a doe to get this
prominent problem addressed because my
suspection would be if in fact I don't
feel good if I'm not here today as
confused I was up earlier this morning
um then how the hell can I possibly
learn anything in this class yeah
so I think that's what um the the
legislation in regards to multi-tiered
systems of support for behavior that
that has where that really kind of arose
from and so we are working across the
state with implementing mtssb
um at the local level so that um schools
have our support but then we contract
with professionals that can go in and
actually implement we have a team
in-house that goes into the school
specifically and will help them to
implement mtssb
but the need is so great that they
cannot just the small team cannot meet
it
um so then we contract with other
partners to go in and particularly look
at some of those more acute some of
those more tier three needs and how that
can then make connections to our
community mental health centers and to
those type of resources so that the
students are getting connected with with
those supports so I think mtssb has been
the department in the states uh in
conjunction also with DHHS on
implementing that piece of it DHHS then
brings in you know a lot of their
wrap-around services and a lot of their
supports as well so that we're working
in coordination with a lot of it so it
is it's a it's a community it's a home
it's a school all effort for for the
students but the mtssb implementation
um it takes time it's not something that
can be implemented overnight so I mean
we continue to work that we continue to
leverage resources to offer it and make
it more available across the state so
thank you both thank you
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair
so
a couple things can you speak to how
many schools or school systems now have
mtssb and then I have another question
also
I don't have the specific number but I
can get that information to you I don't
have it on the top of my head excuse me
ballpark I mean is it half is it 20
percent
yeah yeah I'm sorry
I would say around 10 to 12 Max percent
say that again please 10 10 to 12 saus
and 12 saus
do we have
yes how many do we have I guess
sausage it fluctuates throughout the
year I think we're at 108 last but I
think there's a couple switching this so
somewhere in there by far the majority
don't have mtssb they may and that we
just haven't I mean collected that
information are you implementing it
mtssb it may be looking like some sort
of other and you know RTI was another
one that was similar that's something
that I'm familiar with um mtssb is kind
of a new iteration of that so they may
have an RTI process that they've
implemented in theirs what does the
acronym stand for or a PBIS process the
positive support okay so districts may
have mtssb and we're working with that
10 to 12 through the office of social
emotional Wellness but the district
could have a PBIS process in place that
they developed 10 years ago that deals
with behavior or they could have an RTI
process that they they began five years
ago that helps to deal with that
behavior so we're aware of the 10 to 12
that work with Kelly's office in this of
social emotional Wellness but there are
other districts that have different
systems in place that we just aren't
working with at this point
do you follow
well
I don't know it's fault but I have
another question so
um
in this way we talked a little bit
earlier in this session
I'm sorry I'm trying to find my note
about this here
um about the possibility of surveying I
think representative cascaden brought
this up
um what schools are actually doing with
mental health education and whether the
current rsas are actually being uh
accommodated followed
and it seems like there's a number of
answers to the discussion going along
that
suggests need for more survey that we we
just plain don't know like a few minutes
ago
um
we don't know how many schools have
adequate intervention teams at least
that was what I understood I feel like
we need a pretty thorough look at this
is a statement not a question sorry
representing dry and then representative
represent dry and I really apologize
um I have to go over to governor and
Council for a number of contracts that I
have to get approved so I I really don't
want to cut anybody off but I'm also
very really nervous because I have a
number of contracts that I want I need
to make sure get
all right through that approval process
can you take one more question
representative right sure
thank you very much
um one I'll need those acronyms PBIS and
rti in a minute and but secondly um
just as a mathematician I'm concerned
that the only data you have is one
survey and I'm wondering if there's more
real-time things that you're seeing
through maybe the empty SSB or things
that we can you know collate locally or
or Statewide that don't necessarily have
to depend on one point of information
correct so that was a specific survey of
the students we were talking about so
that question asked about surveying of
students and that piece of it I that's
where we use the Y RBS because we can't
really go in and Survey students we have
partners and vendors that we can
contract with that can do some of that
work at the local level but we at the
department can't go in and do that
um necessarily with the evaluation of
how mtssb has been being implemented
across the state we have partnership
with Bhai as our evaluator for that so I
can send the most recent report which is
going to be December of 2022
on the state of mtssb and implementation
across the state so I can send that to
the committee and then we anticipate
having that updated
hopefully fall to winter of 2023 to give
more even more information on that
okay thank you very much uh good luck
with it
the executive Council Jane you want to
quickly give you the acronyms that you
asked for if you don't mind
um so PBIS is part of positive
yeah
and RTI is response to intervention
Jane you want to come forward
well Jane's getting upwards mtssb can
take years in a district to get into
place I know Manchester started with one
school in 2020 and seeing how that's
going it's going to go into nine schools
in this fall and I mean Manchester has
23 schools so I think it takes a long
time to see how it and it's different in
every school the what you have to
develop and the resources you provide so
you know they may have only 12 that they
think are doing it but some places may
be doing it one school just to try it
first so it's hard to tell
uh remember
I just wanna
close my comment on the front last
presentation it's clear to me that we do
not have a Statewide Equitable process
to help youngsters who have mental
health issues in our Public Schools yeah
and we're not we're not providing
anything it's it's catch and catch can
be on each locality
um and that that concerns me yeah well I
think one of the things that once uh
Jane and her group gets through uh is to
identify the questions that the
committee needs to address and that that
clearly is it's one of the questions
that needs to be addressed as far as
then of what we want to look at when we
come back in the fall so as we look at
these inputs that we're getting this
morning I think the goal is once we get
through with the final presentation here
is to say what are the critical
questions that we need to begin to look
at so that the resources can be then
identified for the for the school so
hold that and bring that back okay
all right Jane you want to introduce uh
your partners there sure thank you very
much my name is Jane Bergeron and I'm
the executive director for the New
Hampshire Association of special ed
administrators and thank you for the
opportunity to have a conversation today
I brought a couple uh special ed
administrators from our membership today
uh Jessica Bickford is the special ed
administrator slash director of student
services for SAU 53 which consists of
Pembroke Allenstown Chichester Deerfield
and epsom
and Andra Hall who is the special ed
administrator for John stock Regional
High School located in Henniker and
where close
so thank you guys for coming I'm just
going to start by giving you a quick
balcony view of some of the trends that
we're seeing um from our special ed
administrators in regards to mental
health in New Hampshire
um when it is specifically for the lens
of special education and then um have
the opportunity for Andra and Jessica to
share
um some of their experiences but more
importantly for you to be able to ask us
some questions so just so that you know
um we've talked a lot about this being a
crisis in New Hampshire mental health is
certainly a crisis nationally when we
talk to our colleagues special ed
administrators around the state so it's
not just a New Hampshire issue it
certainly is National and over the past
five years we have seen a rapid increase
in the number of Children and Youth who
are experiencing mental health
challenges and some of the challenges
are tied to behavior and discipline and
yet some are those silent mental health
challenges that are more related to
anxiety isolation depression and and
just removing themselves from wanting to
be in the school
um environment the numbers of um
Children and Youth being referred to
special education due to mental health
and behavioral challenges has
significantly increased in the past
three to five years
and I think um you know our colleagues
here can share a little bit more about
that
um and the also the other thing that
we're seeing is the number
um and availability of private special
education schools
um we're having a a big increase in
numbers of kids who are being referred
to out of district and out of state
schools and our in-state programs are
full
um and we're seeing more students who
are being referred out of state which is
is just a shame for us to have to
experience that we're also seeing that
um you know part of this crisis is the
the Staffing challenges we've got an
increase of kids who are extremely
complex and we don't have the special
education teachers that we need we don't
have the school psychologists we don't
have the social workers
um the folks that we need to service
these people we just can't get
um so that makes the the challenge even
even more complex for us here in New
Hampshire
some of the factors that kind of that
you know when talking um with the
regions around the state
um that we see that are connected to
this Mental Health crisis is that
obviously the impact of covid and the
isolation um that that brought to our
children youth and families the opioid
crisis
um and substance misuse is connected to
all of this and it's really having an
impact on the Children and Youth um in
in New Hampshire the research is telling
us that social media is playing a part
in this in terms of Mental Health
we're seeing a big shift in terms of the
family and home situations we're seeing
more and more students placed in Foster
placements
um very complex kids ending up living
with their grandparents who are not
always equipped to be able to handle
these children who have gone through a
lot of trauma we are seeing kids who are
very complex with mental health needs
moving back and forth between varied
families
um they're they're pretty mobile so
that's another Factor that's really
impacting some of this crisis we also
see
um you know a lot of inequities in terms
of our school systems in terms of
resources and supports and interventions
to be dealing with this
the other piece of this um that I think
we've heard over and over is the the
silos and the lack of intersection
between our education system our Mental
Health Systems
DHHS our department of Ed we're all kind
of working in silos we all have our own
resources and it's very difficult
um for the integration which is really
critical when we think about this crisis
in terms of solutions there is no Silver
Bullet for sure we need to have you know
more systemic interventions we need more
support and training for our staff we
need staff and the resources as we just
heard uh Patty talking a few minutes ago
multi-tiered systems of support is a
systemic
um initiative it takes three to five
years you need the staff you need the
resources and you need the interventions
to be able to really wrap around kids to
be able to pull that off
so today in our schools we're seeing
really really complex kids with really
significant challenges that we have
never seen before our teachers need to
be able to have the support and training
to be able to deal with that
um you know it's actually starting to
create a wedge between General and
special ed our general Ed folks just
feel as though they're not equipped
they're not ready and and many of the
students you know are referred to
special education because that's where
they can get the help and the support
um so we it really needs to be addressed
as an as a state as a entire uh
community of all of us if we're going to
move forward so from the balcony those
are some of the trends and patterns that
we're seeing across the state
um and before I turn it over to my
colleagues would it open up any
questions if you would have them
hmm
yes representative
thank you I just have a question um you
asked about or you mentioned the um
mental health being not just a New
Hampshire issue but a national issue are
the Staffing challenges also a national
issue
especially in special education yes when
we talk nationally to our colleagues um
it's a it's a huge Challenge and because
our student populations are becoming so
complex and the resources aren't always
there
a lot of people aren't going into the
field of special education we talk to
our Institutes of higher ed
and I'll just use Keen for example you
know historically they would have
graduated over a hundred special
education teachers this year was around
15.
um so we're not we're just not getting
people to go into the field because it
uh yes representative Drive
thank you
how would we measure success if we you
know as we attack these different
problems I mean we give money for sport
and training how would we measure that
that's the place where we know our
money's making making good progress or
systemic intervention or any of those
categories you just listed and I'm going
to turn it to my colleagues you know I
would just say generally if there is a
solid multi-tiered system of support
there is a data collection system
attached to it and it would tell you all
kinds of decreases or increases in
behaviors
decreases in referrals to special
education but I'll let you guys speak
more to that because you live it every
day
okay I would say one of my first
um pieces that I would look for is for
our special education numbers to fit
into what the standards said should be
right so I would refer to the tier one
two two tier three system and
um I'm sure some of you have seen the
triangle of supports that the majority
of your kiddos should fall into that
tier one system right and then your tier
two you have a little bit bigger or
smaller of a chunk and then only one to
three percent of your population should
fall into that tier three intervention
system and support So a measure of
success for I would use for myself in my
districts is if we aligned more so where
that tier three data says we should
align that to me would mean our systems
are working and our supports are working
for our kids
um and I think to mirror what Jane had
just said was that if our special
education referrals were to be at what I
would consider more typical
um just for one example one of our
programs in our district had over 50
special education referrals this year
which is astronomical
foreign
yeah I I had um heard a stat recently
that um our tier three is about 10 right
now so that's kind of where you would
Benchmark it off of that and move
towards that one to three percent
representative Damon
thank you
so
could you comment further on
students being referred into special
education for mental health services
that
and correct me if I'm wrong here
yeah it sounded to me like these are
referrals that would not conventionally
have been special education referrals
but because of the lack of services
being otherwise available
a student who would not generally have
been considered needing special ed
services is getting
inferred in that way
is that correct and could you comment
further on that do you want to speak
today
that that's true it's that we it's
because of the lack of services I mean
we have kids that are on wait list for
two three years for counseling services
and that those counseling services in
order for them to get bumped up in the
system they have to
um you know I had a kid who had to go
sit in Concord Hospital for 10 days to
get bumped up on that list to get the
support that he's needed for two years
so and and still ended up discharging
because he was okay right
and didn't get those further supports
but is bumped up on the wait list at
least so I guess something was
accomplished within those 10 days
you know I'd say to add on to that
um
you know we've got a significant amount
of kids who need therapeutic supports
that schools don't necessarily have
those types of counselors on board right
that would be like your Riverbend Mental
Health Center that has those kind of
counselors involved and I think families
feel hopeless sometimes and want their
kids needs met because they see what
goes on at home sometimes we have extra
supports at school that we may not
always see the same things that parents
are seeing at home the kid may fall
apart at home but is able to maintain
during the school day because they've
got dozens dozens of adult supports or
other services they might be getting
through a 504 instead of an IEP so I
think sometimes families feel helpless
and maybe teachers do as well and so
that adds into those referrals because
they know they need something and they
figure maybe we can try special
education and maybe that will give us
something I will say I tallied up our
number of emotional disturbance
identifications which have gone higher
in the last sample Years and we're at 46
which is a very high number for kids
identified as having an emotional
disturbance or disability
if
Statewide we were to
have more comprehensive mental health
education built into the curriculum
vigorously and
you know starting from a young grade
level
would you see that changing some of this
over time in other words would there
potentially be less students who have
okay
yeah
I'll hit a knee-jerk reaction answer I
guess
um and then maybe Jane you can fill in
where I need but
I think that's only one piece of the
puzzle
um yes that would be helpful but I think
there's a bigger picture of better
communication and collaboration between
mental health providers doctor's office
or primary care physicians and schools
that is currently missing or lacking
that needs better alignment
representative
thank you Mr chair
um I like the sound of that so
um
so what what I'm hearing is that is that
special ed referrals
from from
um you know
mtssb or or other programs that may be
in the school are happening because
other resources are not available is it
is that correct
I would say so I mean I think that there
that everyone's grasping for straws at
once they reach that level they're
grasping for straws they're just trying
to get something
and special ed has a system that's in
place so that's something that they can
land on okay and then and that's my
follow-up on this so what does special
Edge I mean I think of special education
as IEPs and meetings with families and
and with principal and and
um
um how does special education get
involved as a surrogate for for um for
other you know uh uh you know
therapeutic or or services and and how
does special education effectively help
the the student
um
effectively help the student
commits
we know in in special education in order
for a child to have an IEP there's a
specific process and legal timelines and
we have to go through all of this and
and the students that we're seeing being
referred do have significant mental
health and behavioral challenges and we
really rely a lot on our school
psychologists
um they're you know take the lead in
doing these evaluations and it's the
team that decides whether or not
um the child's disability is really
impacting
um their ability to learn and in most of
these cases the disability is
drastically impacting the child's
ability to learn if there were more
resources maybe they wouldn't have
gotten to that point
um and so you know that
logistically and legally they meet all
the requirements and they get an IEP
um so that's basically how it how it
happens does that help it well it'll
follow up on let me follow up on you on
your questions yeah so so the the query
I would have the following uh David's
question was
how do you ensure that special education
services don't become a Dumping Ground
for other emotional issues that may have
I mean that's I think it's kind of
related I think that's absolutely
related and I think the other related uh
thing is is is special education
services
um uh directed towards treating the
mental health condition or modifying the
education program to line up with the I
mean the disa yeah to line up with the
disability because to me that doesn't
sound like the optimal solution here I
mean it's mental health is different
right than physical and and
developmental disabilities
is that it can be until it manifests
itself to a point of that right right
that point is that you know if we had
had the availability or collaboration of
services from outside providers or
additional Services in-house that could
have treated that student through the
mtss system or the tiered intervention
system that schools have in place prior
to that it wouldn't have manifested
itself to the point of a significant
disability in the classroom setting and
I think that goes right to Mills yeah
yeah I think that another thing to it
goes back to the Staffing issue is that
all of our school psychologists are
testing all day long and they're not
able to provide that tr2 or tier 3
support that they're also in schools for
because they're only one person and
they're doing all this testing because
of all the referrals and so that they
don't have the time to spend it with the
kids providing those intervention
providing those preventative Services
so that goes back to that staff
I think one thing I wanted to add on
from I think your
um question earlier is like what's
special about special ed it really
it's a wrap around that's when you get
the outside providers involved that's
when you get that more collaborative
small group individualized attention for
these kids who need these things
um
including Mental Health primary care
physicians dcyf other agencies that
maybe could help or are involved already
special ed is kind of that piece where
you're forced to get all those people
together which really makes a difference
for a lot of these kids
represent Woodcock and representative
blakis next
thank you chairman hey two questions one
written notices showing uh
um the school psychologist
um to me it's sort of like a misnomer
everyone here you have a school
psychologist yet I'm here you're saying
what I have seen for the end of the
visit a while
um that they're testing evaluation
mechanism they're not a service
mechanism they're not a therapeutic
medicine for the most part particularly
now with the number of folks you have
come into the system is that would that
be accurate well they're there to
they're supposed to provide all those
services but but the priority of need is
becoming the testing yes testing
evaluations take a term that okay father
I think this is true
um the second part was
and and I'm not selling to use the word
dumping and I don't think dumping is the
correctly session word but my concern is
that uh as Jane said that the general
education population of faculty
don't have the capacity or skills
uh and then you take the behavior
disorders and throw them in the regular
classroom uh it makes it more difficult
uh and I'm thinking and if I'm wrong
please sorry so I'll go down the wrong
track here but the numbers of uh mental
health issues that we're seeing migrate
to the top now a significantly higher in
the last say two or three or four years
the last two or three years particularly
uh than over the last five or ten years
would that would that be a fair
assessment
if that's accurate then should we stop
thinking on a wider scope of maybe the
schools schools as a as a as a teaching
learning student body program have to
start looking at providing Mental Health
Services for students uh I mean our
guidance counselor for the most part
aren't from my perspective and those
respect to guidance also on the
committee
um I trained in significant mental
health issues uh the depth of the
problems in order to have the sufficient
numbers in the schools to deal with that
so Martin if if maybe we need to start
looking at a different model of bringing
uh Community Mental Health types of
services into the schools not abandoning
them because they surely have full of
what they're doing right now but I mean
as a part of the school system and maybe
relooking how he staffs kids
particularly during this crisis period
is that is that something that's been
dialogued amongst the professional folks
in that area or my way off base no
you're right on Target and I will say
that Riverbend and currently does have a
program where they go into some schools
and there will be a counselor who will
provide services in the school district
setting however there's a limit to what
kind of service they can provide in a
school setting because kids with severe
trauma or things like that they will not
treat in a school setting because of the
type of Counseling Services needed and
the recovery time after that session so
they typically when a kid has an intense
session with a therapist they they need
some time to kind of debrief soak it in
and not go be thrown back into a
classroom full of peers that might
trigger them all over again so that is
let me support that kind of concept and
actually having mental health centers in
our schools so it's not just you know if
the if the family is dropping off a
child and they need to have that support
or look for resources
um to have those kinds of things Under
One Roof
um and and more connections with our
medical world also I think we would
um I I am lucky enough to have a tier
three mental health support system in my
school effective School Solutions
they're a contracted service that come
in and they provide services up to for
up to 20 students Mental Health Services
that include um individual therapy group
therapy and family component which I
think is probably the most
important piece of that is because of
that real true wraparound for students
but because it's a contracted service
and they have their own program there's
a lot of red tape for any
once we once we cross into the medical
world there's a lot of red tapes and so
that's the other barrier barrier
sometimes can just ask her one fall to
the comment get this in that comment
um so the youngsters that are being
serviced by these professional
contractors are coming and helping
um although youngsters typically on IEPs
or these youngsters who just have mental
health especially behavioral issues that
thank you so much thank you it does come
through our mtss process referral thank
you representative Lakers and
representative Cornell okay I have now
three questions that keep growing
um
I'm curious
my understanding of mtssb is that
um
once you get to tier three
you're not doing that in the school
you're doing that out of the school
right you
sending the kids
to one of those Services that's not in
the school and maybe I'm wrong about
that but what I'm wondering is why we're
um
Services I guess
in the school as opposed to outside of
working with the kids and the families
and setting them up with something in
the community
where if it does I mean it can take a
long time right sometimes it can take
hours you know counseling sessions that
are fairly long multiple times and why
are we trying to do that in the school
setting instead of in addition to the
school setting so that's my first
question
commit to it oops sorry
I I think that that's exactly what what
it needs to be both in the school and in
the community because the kids spend a
significant amount of time in school so
there needs to be some support when
they're in the school system when
they're in the school setting but
they're also many of these students
needed a full wraparound
and I'll just add on to that to answer
the first part of your question when
students get to that top tier of
intervention support the majority of
that Sports actually in-house it's not
necessarily us sending kids out
there are very minimal students that we
choose to move to a more restrictive
setting and that ends up you 99 of the
time going through the special education
process and the team determining that we
cannot meet the educational needs of
that child and they need to go to a
specialized school but that's few and
far between the majority of our kids get
those
um
really in-depth intervention supports in
the school setting it just might be that
they're being removed from the classroom
to access those kind of supports or they
have an intensive wraparound team
um and maybe there's a facilitator
that's coming from UNH
um to do a wraparound type approach with
that team of teachers and family members
and the students okay yeah I wasn't
thinking of sending them to another
school I was just thinking of in
addition to the school time outside of
the school time
um just to add on to the outside of
school time piece too is a lot of times
we do help the families get connected to
a mental health provider but we can only
get as far as making that connection we
can't actually get the parent to follow
through on the mental health services
piece and a lot of the mental health
service providers are in the same
position Schools are they don't have
staff and so therefore that kid gets put
on a waiting list for two years because
they don't have counselors who can take
that kid off the case which goes to my
next questions which is where I started
um
you talk about school psychologists and
whatever and I'm thinking well yeah it's
big school districts have school
psychologists but we have an awful lot
of school districts that are small
that don't have school psychologists and
who deals with these things in those
small districts
so even our sorry
I think the vast majority of our school
districts have access to school
psychologists even if they're part-time
and when they don't
um they contract to have um
psychologists come in and provide those
Services whether they be counseling or
evaluations for students
and then and I and I do believe as the
numbers of special ed teachers have gone
down the numbers of school psychologists
have gone down to significantly okay so
what started out as my first question
which is now my third is do you see any
kind of solution or perceive of anything
that's going to grow our
um number of
providers you know because that keeps
shrinking and so and this is everywhere
right so
do you see any kind of solution anything
that can be done
I mean I think that we're competing
against you know big hospitals that can
pay you know these enormous sign-on
bonuses that's that's what we're
competing with in the fields is is that
like and School nurses are the same
thing you know nurses are getting five
thousand dollars sign-on bonuses come
work for our school that's not it's okay
and I think there's less than about 20
things we could do to get to that point
but I think it's going to take reform
and
multi-systems working together so the
like you guys talked about higher ed
revamping the way that those people are
getting trained and equipped to deal
with what has happening in the schools
and not necessarily what was going on
over 30 years ago in school settings
it's it's revamping the way that uh
doctors offices Mental Health Providers
are working together with the schools
and you know the way that this the state
is working and the department is working
I think all those things kind of need
reforms to better work together and then
we could see those kind of results but I
think that's a long tedious process that
includes multiple life checklists well
you're talking about the checklist is it
possible for you to write something up
well but it's a starting point right but
apparently it was the idea that only 15
instead of this large number
I mean how do we deal with that because
if we're not we're only having a small
number coming in and I'm sure we're
well I think other things aren't going
to help related to what representing
like is are there models in other states
I don't have that information but we can
I can check with our national colleagues
but nationally it is a real challenge
getting people to go into the field in
New Hampshire is is not at all
competitive in terms of salary
um and with our growing numbers of kids
with disabilities and becoming more
complex it's it's a truly a really
challenging job and same with our school
psychologists competitive wise in terms
of
um salaries
um you know the the from what I
understand those who graduated from
Plymouth all left the state just because
you know they they could make much more
across the border when they do their
practicums they get paid practicums
wherein in New Hampshire that's not
typical it does happen in some cases but
even for their practicums they will
leave the state
um we're just not competitive resources
are tough
representative Lakers she also thank you
very much I've got uh Cornell cascad and
Damon you're all set okay uh cafskin I I
am also concerned about the time
uh because what I want to do is to take
the final questions then I want to take
a break and then come back and then kind
of focus on some of the questions we
need to deal with okay so representative
Kat scadden thank you
um just a couple of questions first I
agree with a representative like I said
mental health therapy
really should be done by the specialized
Fields but schools need to have the
multi-tiered systems of support to be
able to manage the student not cure them
just manage that behavior but are you
finding that the teens or parents are
requesting one-on-one Ed assistance for
those kids that are finding are having
difficult functioning I mean I used to
see that and we're getting we're getting
doctors prescriptions for them yeah so
okay this is so that's out of control
too
because everybody wants a private
one-on-one educational assistant who
doesn't come with the training by all
means and it's a Band-Aid
and it pacifies people because it keeps
the student out of the classroom
and it just barely you know keeps it
under control but I was curious about
that because I experienced that as well
I mean people want we'll give them a
one-on-one Aid
well you know what you're talking well
only 35 000 salary probably but
you know what you said it's a Band-Aid
really because personally not
a certified professional right I mean it
doesn't mean that they're not great they
could be great but they're not a trained
educator
um and when you have multiple
one-to-ones you add multiple adults and
rightful areas for and you need spaces
patience spaces things like that and
ultimately you know could there be a
redesign in the system or more Universal
Design for Learning in the classroom
more co-teaching opportunities that
could change the need for the one to one
and not need that but
redevelop the system of Education in the
classroom and additional supports from
Mental Health Providers counselors
things like that that could help support
those needs but you are seeing that oh
yeah because on a rock yeah I mean
that's the cost of the local getting
orders from doctors for IEPs yeah like
ones things like that they may not have
and they're going from the word from the
parent which is okay and that parent is
advocating for their child which is
great
um but they may not have the kind
context and the data from the school
correct I've been through that yep thank
you just curious about the one-on-one
increase representative Damon
thank you
I'm wondering if
the testing always needs to be done by a
psychologist or is there any model where
a lower tier provider like an MSW well
icsw are they qualified to do that
testing and respecting that there's a
profound shortage of those folks as well
but just would that be a way to free up
psychologists to provide more of the
supports not just the testing
I think I'm just going to refer to our
special ed rules there are certain types
of disabilities that require certain
evaluators and that's kind of what we
have to go by that's my question yeah
for each category there's certain
evaluations that need to be accomplished
and then it tells the law is very clear
on who can administer those so is it
always a psychologist
um
for
like intelligence testing yes
um
for
social emotional
it requires absolutely yes
um
a psychologist or a psychiatrist
thank you all right I'm going to take
one more question I just I don't think
those other people are any more
available than the school psychologists
are to me
one more question just another
um piece to answer hopes question is
that a special ed teacher can become
safe certified
right and they have the capability to do
the in-house testing for some
intellectual
yes disabilities right so it may save on
a school psychologist
it's back to the special ed teacher
piece you know right right then it goes
back to a special ed teacher it wants to
okay one last question representative
drive thank you could you just clarify
what law that is that test that does
that is a state federal
that decides who tests for what these
are special education rules rules from
New Hampshire yes okay thank you thank
you all right thank you uh for your
presentation obviously this is a very
complex issue and what I want to do now
is I want to take a 10 minute break
and then I want to come back and have a
committee talk a little bit about what
we've heard this morning
and what are some of the questions that
we may want to identify and look forward
to our work in the fall okay so let's
come back in about 10 minutes after 12
okay
thank you for for all of you for being